[Musique]
pas si vous avez déjà eu un cours en
ligne surtout des coraux ma tante
chimilin ça peut être particulièrement
difficile de rester concentré faut que
sur la matière les hauts et les bas de
l'école en temps de pandémie 13 heures
sa frappe est resté vraiment le fait de
moins voir mes amis qui je serais vous
courrez vite pour ces zones avec reçu
sera chose qui ne me tue automne 2020
une rentrée masquer des bulles classe
pour les plus jeunes l'école en ligne un
jour sur deux pour les plus grands une
vague de covile
suivie d'une autre
puis la vaccination pour les adolescents
des chercheurs en éducation à l'une des
chaires unesco de l'uqam se sont penchés
sur l'année scolaire
2020-2021 qu'on voulait mesurer le
bien-être l'anxiété l'inquiétude et la
motivation des élèves dans certaines
matières scolaires plus de 600 élèves et
autant d'enseignants de trois centres de
services scolaires du grand montréal ont
été sondés une fois l'automne une autre
fois vers la famille parce que ça fait
en sorte qu'ils sont restés à peu près
au même niveau ou est-ce que ça nuit à
certains malgré l'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire au printemps dernier
deux groupes sont restés plus anxieux et
moins motivés que les autres les élèves
en difficulté et les finissants du
secondaire on le voit surtout si dans
les entretiens qu on a pu mener avec le
personnel scolaire avec les enseignants
les directions d'école où ils ont
observé des niveaux jamais vus ben de
travail social plus d'interventions
d'élèves en dépression qui ont dû
abandonner l'école les premiers
résultats sont sans équivoque les grands
du secondaire ont écopé les deux
dernières années j'ai dû beaucoup
travailler sur moi j'ai dû augmenter mon
organisation pour être capable de suivre
garder la concentration sur ces corps en
ligne quand d'autres accents la maison
c'est difficile et les notes paraissent
beaucoup pas facile de mesurer les
apprentissages des élèves parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu des preuves ministériel
et seulement deux bulletins au lieu de
trois alors ici pendant le ski de fond
qu'on appelle classique cette
enseignante en sciences constate que
parents et élèves ont perdu des repères
importants de la réussite scolaire au
niveau du travail des enseignants nous
avons fourni l'essentiel de ce qu'ils
ont à apprendre maintenant la réception
sage et des groupes les élèves qui ont
le plus de difficultés mais je suis
vraiment le feeling qu'on quand les cons
qu'on libère davantage on peut aussi se
dire que les enfants et les adolescents
ont fait d'autres types d'apprentissage
l'apprentissage est un processus
complexe ça ne se fait pas que par un
examen et est la réussite à un examen
l'arrêt scolaire du début de la pandémie
en europe pour un certain nombre d'année
des impacts on sait pas pour combien de
temps l ocde a évoqué pour cinq six ans
on espère que les études actuelles
permettront de bien cibler l'aide pour
les élèves qui auront le plus souffert
de ce parcours en dents de scie oui on
peut supposer qu'on va y avoir une perte
d'acquis on n'est pas dans la croyance
que c'est une génération sacrifiée ce
type ce mondial où sion pour voir que se
pose sa touche pas seulement qu'un autre
système scolaire je pense on a pris pas
mal l'essentiel on manquerait de
pratiques exemple en sciences et
laboratoire on en effet mais pas trop on
a le aux cgpi moment qui aidé certains
éléments compo qu'on ne repose mais qui
ont pas être trop difficile à rattraper
je pense ces élèves croient aussi qu'ils
ne seront pas privés comme les
finissants de l'an dernier de leur bal
une autre raison pour eux d'être plus
optimiste